hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Selina
Meyers very appropriate I love it
Selina brand new to the channel I asked
her to come on I'm gonna be performing
at an event called color my energy so if
you guys are california-based definitely
come out you're the project director you
helped create the event but she like
hosts them too and so yeah you do you do
a lot I do and so I I wanted to bring
her by I'm gonna be reviewing the video
today called troll by Shane hikes and
Khoisan yeah oh but you haven't seen the
first one I saw the other one to this
day you haven't seen it yet have you no
okay
let me show it to show me that one real
fast so that made me cry again oh I feel
things I'm probably gonna get emotional
again but if it's anything like yeah I
tell you it's a very moving poet there's
pain but there's like there's so much
more yeah that's so depressing cuz like
this it's light and dark yeah yeah it's
it's all it's all the colors yet in the
tunnel yeah Ryan I I believe that I do
pilot I'm ready to feel things when
once upon a time you
and all your kind they've done
underneath bridges had ridges for ribs
that dropped off into empty chests as if
your hearts were all stolen treasures
it's been excavation crew were hired to
dig up and remove the part of you that
let you feel and while the world above
you invented the wheel you stay put
knowing would one day need to roll over
top of you to get to where it's going
you had an endlessly flowing supply line
of food you can the brood over humanity
and the meals of our hope as if crushing
our spirits would make your mirrors cast
better reflections on the ones they gave
is it the only way you could save
yourselves was to make the world ugly so
no one would notice you hide in it
you learn to knit pain into a kind of
camphor treated hope like a mirage that
you could use to lure in your next meal
you'll live off of our fears you can
taste what we fear every night that time
story is the sunlight
you took darkness is an invite to head
out into the world you curled your hands
to wrecking balls your breath became
squalls you made rocks Rumble you made
land shiver you made boys and girls pray
that someone would deliver them from you
you're real then one day
change but you all say the same just
migrated from living underneath bridges
to living underneath information
superhighways days and nights became
meaningless each already deep in chest
we came in abyss that no one would ever
find the bottom of concepts like love
fell into your gravity we turned
ourselves into life preservers hoping to
save as many as we could with the
fathers who stood guarding closet doors
and the mothers who secured the floors
underneath beds all shook their heads
not knowing how to deal with you who
crept into our lives with tones like
knives stabbing your words into our skin
you began to begin uploading yourselves
into our home directing kinder screens
for eyes and software for bones
you turned your hate into stones and
hurled them at beauty as if you couldn't
bear to see anything other than ugly
anything different you had fingernails
like flint and scraped them alone
decency hoping we would be the ones to
all catch fire you all had smiles like
only barbed wire not meant to keep the
samples yet
place like a firing main you spoken
explosions it isn't cute strangers into
death
and as each family learns to graft skin
over the wounds you gave them you have
yourselves into the scar you have coaxed
the sober back into bars handed out
cigars and memorials F reduces cliffs
and pills to those who unfortunately
found you before they found help praise
the suffering thoughts in between
tragedies gracefully to beat misery as
if you would somehow be impressed with
the dexterity of your animism you have
cheered all right - through police de
visite finish line in a race look at me
even though you somehow see this as an
invitation to your keyboards in two
categories don't ring which one of you
can be the first day this past your
lower or
get ready to incite range a speech a
message what is a stage where you recite
hostility training freedom of speech in
difficulty we are stuck with you the
same way you are stuck with you your
mind is glue and it keeps malice passion
there like cheap wallpaper
we were once upon a time told that none
of you exists we dismissed you as
make-believe or myth now I'm only with
resolve we can no longer afford to tell
ourselves and you weren't real we will
not let you make your dinners out of the
things we feel I just got a say like
right up front
I've been more vulnerable lately and
that [ __ ] is so hard I don't know why
but what if the cameras pointed at you
you don't want to kind of cry with them
that makes you want to cry more right
together I well now I feel like I'd be
forcing tears if I did it guys because
I've already put up my wall to the tears
crying it's okay I I do believe that
actually I've cried many times let's
chat before we go into the poem I just
want to say like the animation and the
music is beautiful
I find myself like sometimes not looking
at the subtitle because I'm just like
more into the animation yeah I tried to
be in both because I'm like trying to no
you're right you're trying to really it
but I want to listen to it I want to
watch it again like maybe two times to
fully understand it no it's it's
something that you can really go into
detail about and really break down I
loved his use of metaphors yeah how he
starts off from like the trolls
perspective and
he's doing like a fairy tale but then it
turns the whole heart being picked up by
a construction crew hidden treasure your
heart as a hidden treasure it's like he
turns these metaphors and same time he
makes things little roll you know
like phrases and sayings the whole
concept of eating your hope like that's
what you're fueling yourself with the
concept of that is just like he says
like you make yourself ugly so no notice
you hiding in it in this world I'm one
of those people who holy [ __ ] okay my
friend I'm one of those people who does
believe at the end of the day you do
create your own world right I'm not
saying like you die and inherit your own
world but if you believe that that's
good for you I I you believe whatever
you want for me I do believe we create
our own world just by the power of our
thoughts and emotions he's like saying
like the world is beautiful but you're
the one who's making your world ugly
right by holding on to these things yeah
time in my life like a poem like this
like really resonated with me because I
was like I felt feelings like this
before but like the feeling of hiding in
myself and not shining any of my life
like the exact opposite ly good or what
am I trying to say it's so deep and he
breaks down the like I've always just
heard so much and studied so much about
the emotional process from like a
logical point of view like you use your
pain as camouflage to learn in your next
meal right I mean he makes you think
about so much what exactly he's
referring to I'm not exactly sure is
probably referring to a lot of things
but for me I think about we sometimes
hold on so much pain that it causes us
to be unintentional manipulators and
it's - that's so true like you could
suck energy from someone like you're in
a low vibrational State and you're
hiding that this is how I see it when
you're in that camouflage and you're
just like hiding from you're hiding your
light yeah like I feel like you are
subconsciously absorbing people's energy
oh you need it you need it
that's it that's what I how I see you
then but that's just mine no yeah they
probably pull yeah it could be anything
that's what art is yeah I love art when
he says you are not real like you fled
into a different part to me I'm thinking
you
come something and then sometimes that
pain causes you to escape it might go
someplace else but then when you go
there you know it's like you're hoping
to create a new identity through what
others see about you yeah holy [ __ ]
I am so intellectual sometimes you are
impressed by brain like I'm thinking of
that prayer like deliver us from evil
yeah deliver us from you but he says you
were not real that's why I mean I
deliver us from you who we want you to
be and view you as is not who you really
are in a way like so some people will
create such a different identity mmm
okay that makes sense but I really get
from this poem is that we have basically
all built a world around us to shield to
shield us from the nature of ourselves
yeah and one could argue that like like
I feel like well it's actually pretty
incredible group how we are now compared
you we're a long time ago okay but
there's also a part of us that has sort
of made other things so much more
important than love and so he says like
love became gravity almost like shelter
I'm significant anymore it's not
valuable at that time I thought he was
gonna shift the poem to be like and then
everything was magical love each other
that's how I thought it was gonna Trish
but I don't watch a lot of videos like
this cuz most of them like the poetry I
listen to it has been like solutions you
know and but I do appreciate hearing
stuff like this because it's a beautiful
piece and which and it does give a
different side of the story like the
future this might be like the future
like where he's transition transitioning
to I feel like he starts off in the
nature of our roots yeah and then like
seeing were the world sort of advanced
into and how this has all become a
distraction from just loving everything
like its kind of reminding me of like
when people say they put so much focus
on materialistic things you know you
weren't looking under bridges anymore
and I are living in their highways where
the world is just going so fast now you
know yeah you think about how it was
only a couple hundred years ago where to
go from like New York to California is a
[ __ ] forever and now we do it like
four to six hours so with everything so
fast and you think about like the kids
kids with cell phones
yeah like I was thinking about like I'm
never gonna give my kid a cell phone not
until like he's a lot older because that
rain it's a processing brain so it's
just like absorbing everything yeah so
you set such a high caliber of like
stimuli you can't focus on being in the
moment right now so deep yeah I think
they're gonna flip it when he's talking
about that part where like the parents
not knowing how to handle you we take
care of you can you think about like
psychology in a lot of ways it's like
everyone usually goes that it links back
to their parents in some fashion you
know like the way how we have become
whatever we hold on to it's kind of dark
in us I imagine like he's talking about
the time and like when parents just were
so against like when being a man men
don't feel your feelings man you know I
didn't even think of it like that but
yeah because they were trying to make
woman behave a certain way and they try
to make men behave a certain way it was
like now we're in a day and age where
it's more about like especially in
California about like be unique but
there is a time where everyone was just
about like block off over your but even
today parents still [ __ ] up sometimes so
you know but I'm gonna be a perfect
parent I want to establish that up front
I'm not gonna make a single mistake I
have done my homework I don't think
that's it's possible it's possible if
it's a boy I'm gonna come right if it's
a girl right Nita Wow
yeah yeah a lot of dads don't like their
daughters like having sex I'm gonna
encourage it
ya know oh yeah your [ __ ] mind Selena
when he's talking about that part about
the barbed wire I think about how we are
so emotional that we will block off
feelings that we are too afraid to deal
with and so we're trying to create that
wall to block it off right what you're
doing is really caging in that feeling
yeah yeah [ __ ] regular everyday like
your prison
your joy and everything all the things
that make you human yeah cuz that's what
a smile does like so many reactions and
like emotions come from your facial
expression exactly he said like there
was an explosion of everything active
everything you caged in yeah that's what
it means like we you don't deal with
things it's like sometimes the trauma
will just overtake you cuz the trauma
overtakes you and I mean that when
person just explodes all of a sudden
right yeah if you bottle that up it's
like bound to just pop yeah exactly like
a baby like a baby or like a soda that
you shake up and when you open it up and
it level
that's why poetic minute yeah I had a
beautiful life being that you turned
into soda and he says like each family
gives graphs to to those you hurt I'm
thinking about how they says like you
become it instead I'm thinking about how
like when we like hurt someone and we
can't just realize we're human and we
made a mistake we don't forgive
ourselves for what we did so we hold on
to that hurt and then becomes a scar wow
that's great like yeah yeah like that I
like that too it's [ __ ] brilliant Wow
I like the way you were thinking about
this cuz like oh it's beautiful it is
very beautiful but like somebody else
might not think the way that you just
thought I know that's why I'm Ryan right
I'm glad we can always keep the tone of
the video consistent at one point he was
talking about how you go into booze
drugs popping pills because you haven't
been able to fun how ya been able to
find help yet and because of that it
just makes you think about how so many
people are so afraid to ask for help
that they will hold on to like they
start doing bosses shame shame is such a
powerful motion and vibration they're
not acting on something so they're
acting out something subconscious now
you have to act on the fact that you
have to you have to look for help you
have to be a little bit vulnerable now
but then they're acting out instead
through these like forms of escapism I
just wanna hug anyone that feel you
think would wanna hug you I would he'll
get everyone in the world I want to have
a giant orgy with all you guys
no we're joggin there's lawyers not the
tired that's the perfect I want to love
everyone in a non-sexual way and I want
us all to see us have sex with each
other
Ryan when he's talking about there's the
police lines and do not cross and then
you dash through it as if you were the
first one well yeah to win the race the
first race person
who in the race to being like awful and
stuff here's my feeling I know I know
Oh what are such a dark please I don't
need therapy you just need this guy to
remind you of all your [ __ ] that you got
going on and one point is talking about
the first two hate is best if you think
about most people this might be just
because of like now that I'm different I
attract it from people into my life I
think that a large part of the world is
so much better at talking about things
they don't like than talking about
positive things like the people who
escape from their problems
right they focus on other problems when
you're when you are in that energy when
you're in that like low vibrational like
depressed sad mad rage all those like
feelings you attract those things into
your life like yeah you just like it'll
just surround you because that's what's
your mirror you're like a magnet for
anything that you exactly whatever
vibrational level you're at that freedom
of speech turning into freedom of
cruelty line it's just badass that is it
is badass
it's like a lie I'm like holy hey he
went there though that's a quote like
that's a perfect quote you could get
that tattooed dad so horribly you're not
good Oh freedom to be a mean jerk I want
the freedom to love I know I want to
make like the opposite of the soup home
he's using these trolls as a metaphor
for a life a lot of darkness in you
right and he's saying we're stuck with
you the way or you are stuck with you
yeah you're stuck in your own prison my
second everyone is in the prison but
you're stuck in that prison inside
exactly
oh the time the poem ends I really do
think that it really is about you got to
be willing to endure the emotional
process because I feel like that's the
message at least it's like especially on
the animation does it say to know in the
poetry but in the animation it says user
blocked like to me it's symbolism for
like by actually blocking your emotions
you're going to create a world that is
actually worse that's hurting then
actually facing it I don't want to say
dealing because that sounds like just
deal with it not I mean like taking the
time to face it which can be really hard
yeah any time consumed it's a painful
journey definitely but it's so worth it
to like really allow like
yourself to like be that highest self
they do you know I think anything about
chakras mm-hmm chakras are your energy
centers and they're the seven energy oh
yeah yeah yeah when you block certain
chakras then you it affects like things
in your life and like there's like the
thought Chaco which helps you like
express yourself if that's blocked that
means like your heart like all your
other chakras aren't gonna work like how
important it is to release and like let
go of things that don't serve you like
one form of suppression leads to other
forms of suppression they just continue
I see this like all as like everything
you go through in your life is like you
have to see it as a lesson like exactly
or and a blessing a blessing and a
lesson because you can learn from
everything there's this book I read that
I love conversations with God if you
guys haven't read it it's just check it
out
it's not a religious book at all sure
atheists you don't care then that's fine
my beliefs are we're all going to the
same places okay I don't care what you
believe because you're gonna end up
where I am in a few years you'll
probably die first your native that's
[ __ ] up I'm sorry
comical music comical relief mmm
depressing yeah but beautiful bow like
conversations with God it taught me that
every experience is truly necessary it
said that in order to understand
anything you have to also understand its
opposite it's like simple stuff Lenore
really understand happiness you gotta
know it's like to be very impressed Andy
yeah exactly because a lot of people
think so black and white with their
emotions they don't realize that there's
such a grey with your emotions that it's
okay sometimes you're gonna feel happy
sometimes you're gonna feel sad
sometimes I'm gonna feel angry but it's
like being honest with your feelings at
the end of the day I think what makes
character is not your feelings
necessarily like people judge their
feelings too much your feelings are your
feelings I feel like the decisions and
the life's choices you make that what
you act upon based off those feelings
the power is in the decision I'm what to
do with that exactly I was just thinking
when you said that like I just realized
that I think I have a lot of people in
my life but the people that I know that
happiest people that have found like you
know peace with themselves are the
people that have had the craziest
[ __ ] lives like you know they've gone
through some really really really hard
dark dark low-low times and now these
people know what it is to feel like
happy you and listen to your genuine
authentic love they know how to nurture
it too because I've had to learn how to
nurture that's what I mean you go
through extreme pain if you know how to
act upon it later on your life at the
end of the day you just got to make a
choice yeah it is like if you're young
and this is happening I totally get it
but if you're like an adult like be an
adult basically if you go through
extremity of pain you're gonna feel
extremity of happiness right you know
you know the difference yeah exactly the
what I appreciate it so much more and I
feel like people also look at subjects
as black and white to like I should feel
this way about it or I should feel this
way rather than going you know I could
have two feelings that coexisting man I
feel you open minded like just the
making the decision to be open minded
and knowing that there are solutions and
if you it's up to you for all the people
that you know really resonate with like
a video like this are feeling sad at
this moment like just know that you are
so powerful if you make the decision
like I am going to be a happy person and
live the life of my dreams then you will
be that person but you have to believe
that like with all of your heart Reds
mystery this video right is a good video
oh god this year is different this is
different you know it's not just dick
jokes this time no dick joke no dick
jokes not gonna mention the dick in this
video I'm gonna live in example like you
know I've gone through some really
really hard times but like when I made
that decision to be happy like to do
what I want create my own reality my
whole life changed when I made that
decision yeah I entire life I heard this
from Jim Rohn he said what may have
happened to you now may not be entirely
your fault but from now on it is your
responsibility hi-five thanks for
sharing that
well yeah thank you great cool fun like
a different side of Ryan right here whoa
right sibu know what I thought who'da
thought haha anyway guys we're gonna
finally wrap this video up if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects where I'm not gonna lie
it's usually not this diva and chelina
as host of this awesome I've just saying
that cuz she's here she's here because
of how much I love this event um color
my energy if you're in California you
got to come out February 76 February 7
February 7 I'm gonna be performing to
you're gonna see more of the two side
yeah oh no we have a whole I'm not done
coming here
sorry there I think the Mike and
Veronica is gonna be performing there to
my wonderful hot girlfriend baby you're
watching your shadow hot here's a
beautiful guttin you are hot
you're beautiful got it on Veronica's
Channel she has a vlog of it I actually
recorded it for her so I'm in the video
too you should really check it out it's
an awesome color my energy event even
have a [ __ ] fire show it's crazy what
I will say about it is every event I go
to of like me I even went to one last
night every music event I go to I'm like
most of the time wishing I wasn't there
that was the first event I went to where
I was like oh my god I love this whole
environment I love the performers haha
awesome
I asked to perform there and so you'll
get to hear some of my spoken word
rhythmic poetry otherwise rap I put I
put magic fluet tree is that what you
have in my category it's like five bucks
but it goes for like nine [ __ ] hours
on like 12 hours 12 hours and it's
awesome it's you literally will want to
stay till the end I wanted to say that
also there is a whole healing realm in
this event with lots of Reiki healing
massage therapy hypnosis acupuncture
divine readings all kinds of amazing
things that you might have never been
introduced to so if you have you feel
any of the feelings that this video has
like and you want if you need some
healing like this is it the event for
you other than how fun and amazing the
performers are there the whole healing
realm for you you could have like a spa
day for like your soul a soul spa day
honey thes a sh t I'm gonna name it that
now yeah I think because we're on camera
we mock out deep we are so great ideas
when I'm on camera I think I should be a
giver all the time yeah hahaha
me on camera all the die so thank you
guys for watching go to facebook.com
slash the real reject shout outs a
result shadow people who love peace and
love Gandhian yah